26 year old making his 2021 debut jace
tingler said he's been stretched out at
the alternate site several innings
possibly tonight 2019 to five games
six in the third innings pitch for the
pirates stepping up to the plate second
baseman adam frazier popping it up right
side ha sung kim
on the dirt of the infield makes the
catch for out number one oh and two to
moran the pitch is hit on the ground to
the right side shift is there hassan kim
has got it and a one two three nine
pitch first inning for miguel diaz tyler
anderson
five starts they've all been pretty good
he's two and two with 338 era
strikeout
per inning pitched just three hits in
six innings his last time out against
the royals gave up one struck out five
grisham aboard and let the games begin
with fernando coming up get to the
shortstop newman goes on a second one
frazier's relay to a double play boy
what a play that was right there and
satis can run
you know he hit it hard enough
fortunately to where you had a chance to
turn
two but uh you got to be quick newman on
the one hopper quickly over to frazier
frazier comes across perfect throw
plenty of time pittsburgh with runners
on the corners two outs one and two on
michael perez miguel diaz ready he deals
and there's a ground ball
diving it's second as hassan gets up and
throws him out
ha
getting the opportunity at second and he
makes a big time play to save a run and
then the top half of the second inning
oh we're gonna hang a star petco park
you better believe it
second base two down here in the third
inning alan moran he's been their best
hitter here he is with a chance to score
a run for pittsburgh in the third inning
swing and a miss good fastball at 95 and
the second strike out of the inning is
the third of the night for miguel diaz
and here comes joe musgrove you pinch it
so that will be the night for diaz look
out on deck circle
grisham had to hop over that hot shot
lined in his direction
that's why no matter where you are you
always watch the baseball scoreless here
in the fourth against the pirates eric
gonzalez leading off on the ground
towards short stop tatis was deep and
short throws on the run and in time nice
play good throw
let's see how much he got on that being
on the move
he threw a bullet to first and gonzalez
is retired yeah and i'm sure jake cronin
over at first base is like oh the closer
that fernando gets closer to me oh my
gosh i got to be on my toes two down
here in the fourth others gonna do
whatever they can to get a base hit off
anderson don't have a hit yet
you're in the fourth inning with two
down and here's manny pops it up right
side of the infield frazier moran are
both there fraser the second baseman
calls for it back pedaling a couple of
steps he makes a two-handed catch and
another one two three inning for tyler
anderson who is rolling right along four
no hit innings for him two down two on
and brian reynolds
coming up here the centerfielder here's
the 1-0 after the mound visit the
reynolds hits it right up the middle off
the side of the map it goes to tatis
thought about stepping on second instead
he throws to first that ends the inning
and that's all for the pirates this mini
rally tyler anderson back out to work he
is yielded one base runner that was on a
walk to the first batter he faced and
erased him on a double play ball trying
to come back from 3-0 here's the payoff
and a swinging ball laced to third and
there was gonzales he'll throw it on two
ops to first and got him great play by
eric gonzalez really nice play over
there
pierre gonzalez picked that up on the
set on a hot
second hop to him and as you mentioned a
two-hop throw in the pick from moran
to retire myers still is not allowed to
hit and jake cronenworth on his way up
ground ball and he knocks it down stays
with him
[Music]
and reaching his conan
i think that's got to be an error it is
an error
still has not allowed a hit error and a
walk as ha sung kim comes up here for
san diego and a swing and a fly ball
to left routine for evans
now one pitch later he's out of it
padres still hitless but an error and
two left one of six no hitters in team
history came against the padres 1970 doc
ellis
swinging a miss for mateo strikes out to
begin things here in the sixth inning
strikeout number three for anderson it's
not been a huge strikeout night but no
oh he's been effective
swinging a miss late on that up and in
fastball another strikeout for anderson
his fourth tonight he's a marvel i love
watching the pitch tatis has had a
befuddling night at the plate he is a
hit into a double play and then bunning
right back to the mound
and tyler anderson
strikes out the side in the sixth he has
no hit the padres through six innings to
the lead off man aboard here in the
seventh and will myers coming up and
will hits this one through the right
side for a base hit first of the night
for the padres and manny's gonna go
first to third
just kind of stuck the bat out might
have even broken it and pushed it
between first and second
a single in the seventh
and the padres with two on nobody out in
a scoreless game
tyler anderson
and not allowed to hit through six plus
but it's myers who pokes one through the
right side into right field and the
padres have their first hit and the
padres best opportunity of the night is
right here in the seventh first and
third no outs family supply ball to
right field polanco towards the corner
will make the catch tagging at third and
scoring is machado tagging it first and
getting to second is myers and the
padres strike first on top one to
nothing
job well done there by tommy pham got
something up he could elevate in the air
he hits this ball to deep part of right
field once again plenty of room for
manny machala to score
and for will myers to move up to second
base looking for more with myers at
second two down and a 1-1 to nola fly
ball towards the gap in right center
field that is going to get down to the
track of the wall
myers coming in nolan is second with an
rbi double and the padres take a
two-nothing lead
this lineup has missed austin nolan more
than one way
obviously
the way that stands out is behind the
dish but
he brings some offense to this lineup
big clutch double here in the seventh
fastball middle away he stays inside
this baseball beautiful splitting the
alley
getting the padres an extra run here
rbi double for austin nola his first
knock of the season mark melance in the
picture of the month of april and the
numbers warrant that in 12 appearances
nine for nine saves no home runs a point
six nine era 14 strikeouts one walk
on the ground to first it's picked by
cudalworth ball game over the padres
were able to shut out the pittsburgh
pirates
[Applause]